[موسيقى]
مساء الخير مشاهدينا انا ميسون واهد واقدم
لكم اخبار الساعه كالعاده نبدا بابرز
العناوين
روسيا واوكرانيا تتبادلان قصف العواصم
وتزايد استهداف الاراضي الروسيه الحدوديه
الاتحاد الاوروبي تعليقا على التصعيد بين
كسب وصربيا اوروبا لن تستطيع تحمل صراع
جديد
اشتباكات تخترق الهدنه الهشه في الخرطوم
والبرهان يظهر من جديد وينفي اي دور
للاخوان في الحرب
انباء عن توافق جديد على موعد الانتخابات
في ليبيا والمبعوث الامامي ينصح بالمصالحه
اولا
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم باتت الحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه
تتخذ منعطفا خطيرا مع وصول التهديد الامني
والعسكري الى قلب العاصمه الروسيه بعد
ليله المسيرات التي شهدت غارات استهدفت
موسكو وكاف وزاره الدفاع الروسيه حددت
النقاط التي تعرضت لهجمات المسيره في
موسكو وثلاث نواحي رئيسيه غربيه العاصمه
موسكو كما افادت الدفاع الروسيه باسقاط
ثمان مسيرات معظمها في موسكو ورغم توجيه
موسكو اصابع الاتهام الا ان مستشار الرئيس
الاوكراني نفذوا الوع بلاده في هذا الهجوم
انتقال جغرافي للحرب بدا جليا من خلال
استهداف قرن ومناطق محيطه ببالغرود
المجاوره للحدود الاوكرانيه حاكم مقاطعه
بالقرود
قال ان القوات الاوكرانيه استهدفت اليوم
مركز اقامه مؤقته للنازحين
الى وجود اصابات وقتله
حرب المسيرات اضحت الوجه البارزه للمواجهه
الروسيه الاوكرانيه كل طرف يسعى الاستهداف
عاصمه الاخر بعدها هجمات متواصله على
العاصمه الاوكرانيه هجوم جديد استهدف
موسكو بالمسيرات فرضيتان اثنتان بخصوص
الهجوم الاوكراني الفرضيه الاولى تتمثل في
استهداف موسكو وانطلاقا من الاراضي
الاوكرانيه خاصه من سومي وهي منطقه تبعد
عن موسكو حوالي 600 كيلومتر الفرضيه
الثانيه تشير الى تنفيذ الهجمات من داخل
الاراضي الروسيه ما يعني وجود خلايا نائمه
داخل التراب الروسي خبراء اشار الى ان
الطرفين يمتلكان مسيرات دواره وذات الجناح
الثابت والانتحاريه ابرز المسيرات التي
تمتلكها كياف طائره اوكرانيه الصنع يبلغ
طول جناحها اثنتين وثلاثين قدما وتستطيع
الطيران لسبع ساعات وتصل سرعتها الى 100
ميلان بالساعه واخرى امريكيه الص تطير
لمده ست ساعات بسرعه 100 ميل في الساعه
فضلا عن المسيرات التركيه الصنع برقدار من
طراز تي بي اثنان والتي يبلغ طولها سته
امتار ونصف تحمل اربع ذخائر موجهه بالليزر
روسيا هي الاخرى اضحت متقدمه مؤخرا في
تصنيع الطائرات المسيره ثابته الجناح
كطائرات اوريان التي يبلغ طولها 14 مترا
وتستطيع الطيران لمده 24 ساعه متواصله
بسرعه 120 ميلا بالساعه اضافه الى
المسيرات ايرانيه الصنع التي تبلغ سرعتها
185 كيلومترا بالساعه وهي كبيره الحجم لكن
صنعها منخفض الكلفه تبلغ هدفها بواسطه
احداثيات نظام جي بي اس يتم ادخالها قبل
اقلاعها وتحلق بعدها في شكل ذاتي على علو
منخفض تصل هدفها الثابته بالضروره على بعد
بضع مئات الكيلومترات بلال الوجد اني
العربيه
لم يتاخر الرد الروسي حيث شددت الخارجيه
الروسيه على ان موسكو تحتفظ بحق الرد
واتخاذ الاجراءات اللازمه للرد على
الهجمات التي استهدفت موسكو اخيرا وادانت
الوزاره هذه الهجمات مشيره الى انها كانت
موجهه ضد المدنيين وتهدف الى بث الخوف
والذار بين المواطنين
خلال اليوم نفذت القوات المسلحه الروسيه
ضربات جماعيه باستخدام اسلحه بعيده المدى
عاليه الدقه مطلقه من الجو على نقاط
مركزيه لصنع القرار في اوكرانيا حيث تم
التخطيط لاعمال ارهابيه بتوجيه من متخصصين
من اجهزه المخابرات الغربيه على الاراضي
الروسيه وتم ضرب كل الاهداف المخطط
استهدافها بنجاح
اما الرئيس الروسي فقال ان الهجمات
الاخيره على بلاده ج
اءت هذه المخابرات العسكريه الاوكرانيه
لم نطلق العنان لهذه الحرب في عام 2014
اختار نظام كيب معادات روسيا واضطهاد
الروس في دون باس ونحن لا نستخدم هذه
الوسائل التي يستخدمها قاده نظام كييف وما
حدث اليوم تاكيد اخر على ذلك المنشات
المدنيه السلميه في موسكو تعرضت للاستهداف
وعلى العكس من ممارسات الجيش الاوكراني
تنفذ قواتنا ضربات دقيقه ضد منشات البنيه
التحتيه العسكريه ومنها مقر المخابرات
العسكريه الاوكرانيه الذي تعرض للقصف قبل
يومين او ثلاثه ايام اختار نظام كييف
مسارا مختلفا مسار محاولات ترهيب روسيا
وتخويف المواطنين الروس وضرب المباني
السكنيه وهذه بالطبع علامه واضحه على نشاط
ارهابي
حرب المسيرات تشتعل بين روسيا واوكرانيا
ابرز المسيرات المستخدمه من كلا الطرفين
طائرات برقدار تركيه الصنع اوكرانيا تعتمد
اساسا على طائرات اوكرانيه الصنع طول
جناحها يبلغ 32 قدما تطير لسبع ساعات
بسرعه 100 ميل بالساعه
طائره امريكيه الصنع تطير لست ساعات بسرعه
100 ميل بالساعه
روسيا هي الاخرى تملك مسيرات متطوره اهمها
اوريان ثابته الجناح بطول 14 مترا تطير
لاربع وعشرين ساعه متواصله بسرعه 120 ميلا
بالساعه وسيارات تشاهد الايرانيه سرعتها
تبلغ 185 كيلومترا بالساعه تبلغ هدفها عبر
نظام جي بي اس
اصنع الهجمات الاخيره التي استهدفت موسكو
وصلت الى البيت الابيض حيث قالت واشنطن
انها لا تؤيد الهجوم على روسيا البيت
الابيض اكد انه لا يزال يجمع المعلومات
بشان هجوم الطائرات المسيره الاخيره على
موسكو واشدد على انه يدعم اوكرانيا
لاستعاده اراضيها فقط
ينضم الي البرلمانيه الاوكرانيه اوليكسي
جون شارينكو اهلا بكم معنا كيف تردون على
هذه الاتهامات الروسيه على الرغم من انكم
تنفون بانكم لستم مسؤولين عن هذه المسيرات
التي تدخل الى العمق الروسي
هل تسمعني سيد جون شارينكو
يبدو بانكسي لا يسمعنا نحاول ان نصلح هذا
الخطا التقني ساذهب الان الى بالقرود
مراسل العربيه عبد الجواد الرشد عبد
الجواد اهلا بك معنا ايضا
بالجروب تتصدر المشهد في هذه الايام كيف
يبدو الوضع هناك واين يتركز هذا القصف هل
يمكن ان تعطينا صوره واضحه عما يحدث
مساء الخير ميسون نعم صحيح ما تقولين هي
الخط الساخن الاول في الشريط الحدودي
الفاصل بين الاراضي الروسيه والاوكرانيه
اسمحي لي بان ان انوه بان هذا الشريط بين
البلدين يمتد لقرابه 400 كيلو متر طبعا
هناك الكثير من المناطق الساخنه التي
تتحدث عنها حكومه هذا الاقليم ابرزها يعني
مدينتي شبينكو
ويعني هاتين المدينتين احداهما تقع في جهه
اليمنيه من جهه اليساريه وتشكلان مثلثا مع
مدينه واقليم خاركيف الاوكراني وهذا يفسر
حسب القراءه العسكريه في البلاد سبب تعرض
هاتين المنطقه لمعظم الضربات التي تطال
الاقليم في اخر التحديثات ميسون ضربه
اوكرانيه بالمدفعيه اليوم طاطال مركز
ايواء
للاجئين الذين تم نقلهم اصلا من المناطق
الحدوديه نحو العمق الروسي نوعا ما طبعا
تم التاكيد على مقتل شخص واحد واصابه
شخصين من الضربه مباشره بينما الجرحى يصل
عددهم الى قرابه العشر اشخاص طبعا كما
يدور الحديث ومن مقاطع الفيديو التي يتم
تناقلها من المناطق الحدوديه وهذا الشريط
ضربات المسيرات ان كانت حامله لعبوات
ناسفه او غيرها من الضربات الصاروخيه
والمدفعيه تاتي بين الفين والاخرى نحن في
مدينه بيليجراد في مركز المدينه نسمع في
بعض الاحيان عمل انظمه الدفاع الجوي حكومه
المدينه تتحدث عن اصطيادها للمسيرات التي
اصبحت تفقد نوعا ما في المدينه لكن طبعا
على بعد 20
في بعض بشكل كبير هل ينزحون الى مناطق
اخرى
وايضا ما هي رده فعل الناس على هذا القصف
ماذا تسمع في الشارع
ميسون عمليه النزوح الرسميه هي مستمره منذ
نحو نصف عام من الان عندما تواجدت العربيه
في الخريف الماضي بدات عمليه النزوح من
الضربات الاوكرانيه لكن اليوم حكومه
المدينه توجهت نحو نقل عدد كبير من سكان
المناطق الحدوديه وخاصه من الجهه الغربيه
نحو العمق الروسي تحدثنا اليوم للكثير من
فئات الناس في الشارع في الروسي في مدينه
طبعا كنا نلاحظ فقد عنصر الشباب نوعا ما
الذي اتجه نحو العمق الروسي او سافر خارج
البلاد لكن عمليه النزوح مستمره اما من
المناطق الحدوديه نحو ميدنيات او من مدينه
نحو مناطق اكثر امانا في الداخل الروسي
العائلات مع الاطفال طبعا تتجه بحثا عن
مستقبل اطفالها بما يخص عمليه الدراسه او
عمليه العمل يعني رب الاسره كما تتحدث بعض
السيدات في المدينه اصبحوا يبحثون عن عمل
باعتبار ان باعتبار ان الاعمال التجاريه
في المدينه انخبط الى ادنى مستوياتها منذ
الحرب العالميه الثانيه هي موجه كبيره هي
حرب حقيقيه ان صح التعبير ميسون يشهدها
الان هذا الاقليم اخر مره طبعا شهد هذه
الضربات الثقيله ان صحى التعبير باعتبار
ان الاقليم باكمله يتلقى بين 2300 ضربه
اوكرانيه حسب روايه المدينه كل يوم لذلك
طبعا الوضع هو صعب نوعا ما معظم السكان
يتحدثون عن ضروره العمل على ايجاد ونشر
انظمه الدفاع الجوي بشكل اكبر لكن طبعا
الموضوع لا يحتاج لتفسير الكثير من
الخبراء العسكريين بان انظمه الدفاع الجوي
لا تعمل بضمان مئه بالمئه ولا يمكنها
اصطياد ضربات القذائف القريبه لذلك عمده
المدينه قبل يومين راحه بعيدا وتحدث عن
ضروره السيطره على تامين الوضع تفضلي كل
هذه المعلومات وهذه التفاصيل هذه الصوره
الواضحه عما يحدث حقيقه على الارض في
بيلغيرودا شكرا لك مراسل العربيه عبد
الجواد الرشد ساعود الان مجددا الى مع
ضيفنا البرلماني
الاوكرانيكو اما الان تكون تسمعنا الان
سيد جون شارينكو ما هي ردودكم على هذه
الاتهامات من قبل روسيا بانكم تستهدفون
الاراضي الروسيه على الرغم من نفكم دائما
بان هذا العمل ليس من جانبكم
هي التي بدات بهذه الحرب غير المبرره على
بلاد بلادنا وقد انتهكت
القوانين الدوليه ونحن يحق لنا ان نقوم
بضرب اي اهداف داخل العمق الروسي واعتقد
انه يجب على الشعب الروسي ان يكون مستعدا
لانها مخاطر هذه الحرب سوف تطالعهم فهم
يقومون بقتل اطفالنا
وسكاننا على مدننا وتستحق روسيا ان تدمر
كليا
روسيا هي دوله شريره
ونحن يحق لنا ان نرد بالهجوم من الاسئله
التي يجب طرحها بصوره اساسيه هو انه اذا
لم ترغب روسيا باستمرار هذا الحرب عليهم
الانسحاب من اوكرانيا والا فان الامور سوف
تستمر نحن لا نود منهم ان يكونوا موجودين
حتى على اي انشاء من اراضينا وان يتوقفوا
عن ادوانهم ومع ذلك سوف ندافع بكل سبل
المتاحه لنا انا لست منكم انتم تتبنون
بانكم انتم من قمتم بقصف الاراضي الروسيه
لانه الحكومه الروسيه وزاره الدفاع
الاوكرانيه عذرا تقول بانها لم تستهدف
العمق الروسي انما الان الان تقول ان من
حقكم وكانكم استهدفتموها انتم
لا استطيع تاكيد هذا الامر
لانني لست متحدثا رسميا لوزاره الدفاع
الاوكرانيه ما استطيع تاكيده في جميع
الاحوال ان الاوكرانيين لديهم كل الحق في
في ضرب اي مدينه موسكو وغيرها في ضمن
الاتحاد الروسي لان روسيا هي التي بدات
الحرب ضد بلادي نحن لدينا الحق من الذي
شرع في هذه الحرب لكنني كما اخبرتك فانا
لست بخبير عسكري قد تكون بعض المجموعات
داخل روسيا
بعض المعارضه داخل روسيا لا اعلم لكن
لحقوا لنا ان نتخذ اي اجراء بحق روسيا
لانها لان الاخيره هي التي تهاجم كافه
المناطقنا على مر الاشهر خمسه عشر الماضيه
سيد جون شارين كل بيت الابيض يقول بانه
يحقق بهذا القصف على الاراضي الروسيه
ويؤكد بانه هو يعطي اسلحه لاوكرانيا لكي
تدافع فقط عن اراضيها وليس استهداف روسيا
او اي اراض اخرى ايضا كيف تنظرون الى هذا
التصريح من قبل البيت الابيض
اننا ممتنون على وجه التحديد للولايات
المتحده ولكافه حلفائنا
ونثمن
كافه
المساعدات التي يقدمونها لنا
واستطيع ان اقول لكم باننا لا نستخدم اي
اسلحه امريكيه او غربيه لضرب مناطقها في
العمق الروسي
مره ثانيه روسيا هي التي بدات بالحرب ونحن
وفقا للقانون الدولي لدينا كافه الحق في
الدفاع عن اراضينا وسوف نفعل ذلك
وتجبر بالاشاره ان اقول بان موسكو سوف
تعاني وسوف تتذوق من نفس السم الذي نحن
نتذوقه وسوف يعاني المواطنون الروسي كما
يعاني المواطنين الاوكرانيين وكما يدمرون
بلادنا شكرا لك من كافه البرلم انيه
الاوكرانيه اوليكسي جون شارينكو
اخبار الساعه سنتابع بعد قليل بعد فوزه في
الانتخابات اردوغان امام اختبار الغرب
بشان الموافقه على انضمام السويد للنيتو
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد الى اخبار الساعه دعا
مسؤول السياسه الخارجيه في الاتحاد
الاوروبي جزيره بوريل قاده كوسوفو وصربيا
الى وقف التصعيد على الفور بعد اشتباكات
وصفها بغير مقبوله على الاطلاق في شمال
كوسوفو وقال ان اوروبا لا يمكنها تحمل
صراع اخر براء الاضاف ان الاتحاد الاوروبي
يناقش الاجراءات التي يمكن اتخاذها في حال
واصل الاطراف مقاومه الخطوات المقترحه
تجاه وقف التصعيد
صربيا وكوسوفو تاريخ من الصراع
في العام
الجنرال تيتو حاكم يوغوسلافيا الاتحاديه
يمنح كوسوفو حكما ذاتيا ضمن يوغوسلافيا
يونيو
1989 الرئيس الصربي يلغي الحكم الذاتي
لكوسوفو الكوسوفيون يبداون سلميا المطالبه
بالاستقلال في
1998 الجيش الصربي يرتكب مجازر ضد
المدنيين الالبان
في مارس
1999 قوات النيتو تشن هجوما على صربيا
والجبل الاسود
يونيو
1999 انسحاب القوات الصربيه تحت ضربات حلف
الناتو
فبراير 2008 البرلمان الكوسوفي يعلن
الاستقلال و واشنطن اول الدول التي تعترف
بكوسوف دوله
صربيا ترفض استقلال كوسوفو
من جانبه اكد من عمل
قوات اضافيه من الحلف الى كوسوفو وذلك عقب
الاشتباكات التي وقعت هناك انيت اضاف انه
اصدر توجيهات بنشر 700 فرد سيكونون في
الحاله تاهب كما قال امينو عام الناتو ان
الاعتداء على قوات الحلف امر غير مقبول
وان على السلطات السريه والكوسوفو واتخاذ
اجراءات لوقف التصعيد
نددنا بشده بالهجمه غير المبرره ضد قوه
كوسوفو والتي ادت الى اصابه ثلاثين من
قوات حفظ السلام مثل هذه الهجمات غير
مقبوله ويجب ان تتوقف ستتخذ قواتنا جميع
الاجراءات اللازمه للحفاظ على بيئه امنه
لجميع المواطنين في كوسوفو سنواصل العمل
بحياديه بما يتماشى مع تفويض الامم
المتحده لقد قررنا نشر 700 جنديا اضافي من
قوه الاحتياط العملياتيه لغرب البلقان
ووضع كتيبه اضافيه من قوه الاحتياط في
حاله تاهب اعلى حتى يتم نشرها اذا لزم
الامر هذه خطوات حكيمه لضمان القيام بما
يجب فعله يؤدي العنف الى نكسه كوسوفو
والمنطقه باكملها ويعرض تطلعات اوروبا
الاطلسيه للخطر
[موسيقى]
الى الملف السوداني الان وفي اول ايام
الهدنه لا تزال المواجهات مستمره حيث افاد
مراسل العربيه بتجدد الاشتباكات العنيفه
في العاصمه الخرطوم بين الجيش وقوات الدعم
السريع واشارت المصادر الى ان الجيش رد
على قصف الدعم السريع بقذائف المدفعيه اما
في جنوب الخرطوم دوت اصوات انفجارات
واشتباكات بين الطرفين وفي ام درمان شهدت
منطقه الافتيحاب اشتباكات خفيفه فيما ساد
الهدوء الحذر مدينه الخرطوم بحري
الاشتباكات جاءت رغم ان ممثلي الجيش وقوات
الدعم الساريات تفاقه في جده على تمديد
وقف اطلاق النار لمده خمسه ايام
[موسيقى]
في المقابل تتصاعد التصريحات المتبادله
بين الجيش والدعم السريع قائد الجيش
السوداني عبد الفتاح البرهان نفى تصريحات
الدعم السريع بان الحرب في السودان ضد
جماعه الاخوان فيما تعاهد باستخدام القوه
التي وصفها بالمميته والمفرطه في حال لم
تتراجع قوات الدعم السريع
الله اكبر الله اكبر
[تصفيق]
الله اكبر
من الهدنه المبرمه مع قوات الدعم السريع
هو وصول المساعدات للبسطاء والمتضررين
شراء الاشتباكات مع قوات الدعم السريع
صحيحنا الناس الفسطوطان المساكين البنات
المغتصبا وبيوتهم حرماتها ومال النهب
بدون ذنب بدون ذنب وبدون سبب
يقولوا الحرب ضد الكيزان
[تصفيق]
الشعب السوداني
من لندن ينضم الينا خالد
الاعسر الصحفيه السودانيه استاذ خالد اهلا
بكم معنا لم نلبس ان نتابع بدء اي هدنه
حتى الخروقات تاتي
ويعني المشهد كله تاخذه كيف يمكن ان يتم
الالتزام بهذه الهدى التي يعني اصبح عددها
لا يحصى
لك ميسون ولمشاهديكم الكرام
بالتاكيد الهدى ربما هذه الثامنه
وثبت الدليل القاطع اليوم انها لم تعد كما
كان مرجوع منها ان تكون ان تحقق حاله من
الاستقرار وقفه النار حتى تسمح بمرور
الاغذيه او الغذاء والدواء للمحتاجين في
تلك المواقع ولكن بالتسلسل التاريخي لهذه
الهدم والهدى منذ ان بدات عاده تحدث
الخروقات من قبل قوات الدعم السريع وهنا
لا بد من الاشاره الجزئيه واضحه للعيان
ربما يعيش الشعب السوداني بيكملوا الشعب
السوداني شعب متماسك نسيج المجتمعي لديه
ارتباطات مع كل الموجودين تحت مرمى
النيران في العاصمه الخرطوم وبالتالي
الجميع في السودان يعلمون ان لديهم اسر في
الخرطوم تم تعييره واخراجها من منازلها
وتغولت على حقوقها قوات الدعم السريع اما
نهبا او اغتصابا او ضربا او ترويعا هذا
ابتداء ثم عمليه الحاجه الى الدواء
والعلاج اثبتت لكل ابناء الشعب السوداني
ان قوات الدعم السريع اخرجتهم من
المستشفيات وحلت محل هذه المستشفى محل
المرض يعني ايضا اليوم الفريق عبد الفتاح
البرهان ايضا صعد كلاميا وقال بانه
سيستخدم القوه المفرطه مع الدعم السريع في
ظل اجواء هدى لماذا هذا التصعيد ايضا
بالتصريحات
لقد اوغل الناس في اتهام مؤسسه الجيش في
قضيه التروي والحكمه التي اتبعتك منهج
اخلاقي في التعامل مع هذه الازمه مع
مجموعات متفلته لا تضع ادنى سقف اخلاقي
للتعامل مع ابناء الشعب السوداني
وقعد عليها مظالم قد لا يقبل اي غايه
متهور او ضابط غير عظيم وليس عظيم ومن ثم
كانت بالامكان ان يرتكب الجيش السوداني ما
ارتكبته جيوش في المنطقه وتمسح الارض مسحا
ممن عليها ولكن الى هذه اللحظه ظلت جيش
السوداني توخى كل القيم الاخلاقيه التي
تحمي شعبه للجيش السوداني هذا المسلك سواء
كان في غايه العام الذي يصدر التعليمات او
في جنود وضباط الذين يقدمون ارواحهم فداء
لهذا الوطن الشعب السوداني هناك غرف حاولت
واجتادت لتفتيل عدد الشعب السوداني
بمحاوله خلق نوع من الشرخ في الصيغه التي
هؤلاء الشعب لجيش هذه الاشياء جميعها
مبررات دفعت غيد الجيش اليوم للخروج
لارسال رسائل في اكثر من بريد اولا بريد
الدعم السريع الذي ظن وهما
وخطا ان حكمه الجيش هي نوع من الضعف الجيش
السوداني متمكن يا استاذه الجيش السوداني
يعلم بحركه اي جندي للدعم السريع في
الخرطوم يصورون من الفضاء البعيد قد لا
يكون هذا الامر مصدق لدى بعض الدول في
الخليج وفي افريقيا لا انا اؤكد لك ذلك ان
الجيش السوداني لديه غمر صناعي عسكري يرصد
الخرطوم زنقه زنجوبيت بيت حتى بطريقه
الرعي معمر القذافي
ان هذا التصريح وانه في اعذرني انتهى وقت
للمقابله اشكرك على المشاركه معنا من لندن
خالد عسر الصحفي السوداني
نتابع ايضا من السودان حيث اصدر وادي
ولايه البحر الاحمر المكلف فتح الله الحاج
احمد امر طوارئ بحظر التجوال في بورتسودان
وينص الامر على حظر التجوال في المدينه من
الساعه الحاديه عشره مساء وحتى الخامسه
صباحا كما يعمل بلبل يعمل بالقرار لمده
تصل الى ثلاثه اشهر
[موسيقى]
الى ملف تركيا الان عقدان من الحكم فتح
خلالها اردوغان ابوابا جدليه على حكمه
قائمه من التحديات تواجه اردوغان في
ولايته الثالثه على راسها العلاقه
المتذبذبه مع الغرب فبحس
التركي تقويه تلك العلاقه مجددا بعد ان
كانت تقارب التركي الروسي سببا اساسيا في
احباط قاده امريكا واوروبا وهو تقارب فسره
اردوغان بالحفاظ على مصالح تركيا هناك
ازمه اخرى مشاهدينا سيواجهها اردوغان
خارجيا ما هي علاقته مع الناتو في ظل
اصراره على عدم انضمام السويد للحلف وهي
المساله التي قد تضغط على اردوغان لتغيير
موقفه حيث تربط واشنطن هذه الخطوه بصفقه
امداد انقره بمقاتلات اف 16
لقد تحدثت الى اردوغان وهنئته هو مازال
يريد العمل على ملف طائرات اف 16 وقلت له
اننا نريد التوصل لاتفاق بشان السويد لذا
قم بذلك وبعدها سنعود الاتصال ببعضنا لكن
المكالمه في الاساس كانت للتهنئه
لم يغلق الباب امام امكانيه انضمام السويد
الى الحلف وقال ان قرارا بهذا الشان ممكن
جدا قبل انعقاد قمه الحلف في يوليو المقبل
اردوغان وتتمثل في خفض اسعار الفائده رغم
ارتفاع التضخم
لكن ايضا هناك سؤال ما مستقبل المعارضه
التي خسرت امام اردوغان سرعان ما بدات
اقطاب هذه المعارضه باستخلاص العبر من
نتائج الانتخابات والاعداد للبناء على ما
حققه مرشحهم كماله حيث عقد اعضاء الطاوله
السداسيه اليوم اجتماعا لتقييم نتائج
الانتخابات واقترح خلاله عدد من قادتها
على الاستقاله من منصبه لفتح الطريق امام
قاده الجدد لكنه رد بان هذا من السابق
لاوانه وتعهد بمواصله ما وصفه بمعركه
الديمقراطيه داعيه ناخبيه الى البقاء
واقفين على اقدامهم لمواصله المسيره
ورغم خيبه الامل التي سيطرت على المعارضه
بعد نتائج الانتخابات الا انها ترى في
التقدم الذي حققته نافذه لفرص سياسيه
قادمه وقال الرئيس بلديه اسطنبول اكرم
امام اوغلو احد قاده حزب الشعب الجمهوريه
المعارض ان تصويت اكثر من 25 مليون ناخر
لصالح مرشح المعارضه يعكس قوه الرغبه في
التغيير وادعى انصار المعارضه الى
الاستعداد للانتخابات البلديه في مارس
المقبل مذكرا بالنجاح الذي حققته في
الانتخابات البلديه والتي اعاقبت خساره
انتخابات الرئاسه عام 2018 كما ذكر بالفوز
في المدن الرئيسيه وخصوصا العاصمتين
السياسيه والاقتصاديه انقره واسطنبول
في اخبار الساعه لدينا بعد قليل الكونجرس
الامريكي في سباق مع الزمن لاقرار اتفاق
رفع سقف الدين العام
[موسيقى]
نتابع من الشان الليبي بينما تستمر
الاجتماعات الليبيه الليبيه في المغرب
كشفت تقارير اعلاميه ليبيه ان لجنه 6 + 6
المشكله من مجلسين النواب والاعلى للدوله
توافقت على اجراء الانتخابات البرلمانيه
في ديسمبر المقبل والرئاسيه مطلع العام
المقبل التقارير اشارت الى ان اللجنه
توافقت على تشكيل حكومه مصغره بمهام محدده
لمده سته اشهر غير قابله للتمديد لتنظيم
الانتخابات والسماح بترشح العسكريين كما
اكدت التقارير ان اللجنه سمحت بترشح
العسكريين
ومزدوجين الجنسيه للانتخابات وعدم السماح
لمن عليه حكم القضائي او مطلوب للعداله
كما اتفقت اللجنه على تقسيم مقاعد
البرلمان لتكون 60% للاحزاب واربعين
بالمئه للافراد
ومع ذلك قال المبعوث الامامي لدى ليبيا
عبد الله بتيلي لان الخروج من الازمه
الراهنه يتطلب عمل جميع القيادات السياسيه
والامنيه والاجتماعيه للخروج من الازمه
الحاليه واكد باتيليا ان المصالحه الوطنيه
هي السبيل الافضل للخروج بليبيا من الازمه
[موسيقى]
ايام معدوده مشاهدينا تفصل الولايات
المتحده عن كارثه اقتصاديه وشيكا وتبقى
عصا الاتزان بيد الكونجرس اقل من اسبوع
امام واشنطن لاتخاذ قرار حول رفع سقف
الدين الامريكي الانظار الان متجهه لقبه
الكابيتال اذ يجتمع مجلس النواب للنظر في
مشروع قانون الماليه والذي هيكله اتفاق
الرئيس بايدن وزعيم الجمهوريين كادن
التوصل اتفاق بشان سقف الدين ليس نهايه
الازمه حيث تمرير القانون بالكونجرس يصطدم
باعتراضات ابرزها ان الاتفاق لا يصل الى
الدرجه المطلوبه من حد الانفاق الفيدرالي
بالاضافه الى الانتقادات بشان القيود
الكبيره على الانفاق والتي يحملها مشروع
القانون ومع ذلك ترى
في طريقهما للحصول على دعم كاف من الحزبين
لتعليق حد الدين في نهايه المطاف
لنوع النبي
انا لا ازعم انني اثق بما سيفعله الكونغرس
تحدثت الى عدد من المشرعين ويبدو لي الوضع
جيدا وسننتظر التصويت
على تعليق الالتزام بحد الدين البالغ واحد
واربعمائه مليار دولار حتى يناير 2005
مقابل تخفيض بعض جوانب الانفاق الفيدرالي
لتتمكن الحكومه الامريكيه من تسديد ديونها
والابقاء على مستوى الانفاق التقديري
وزيادته عام 2025 بنسبه واحد في المئه وهي
اموال يتم توجيهها الى الاسكان والتعليم
وغيرها من البرامج الفيدراليه
منح مجلس النواب 72 ساعه للاطلاع على
مشروع القانون قبل التصويت عليه
لكن الاتفاق لم يتضمن التخفيضات الكبيره
التي يريدها الجمهوريون
ومع ذلك مشاهدينا والرغم التصريحات
المتفائله الى ان تمرير القانون قد يواجهه
عقبه اجرائيه قبل الخامس من يونيو الجاري
وهو الموعد الذي قد تفتقد فيه الحكومه
الامريكيه للاموال وتعجز عن دفع مستحقات
ديونها وفواتيرها ومعاشات التقاعد ورواتب
الموظفين الفيدراليين عمق هذه الازمه هو
عدم حسم الامر بعد بسبب معارضه شديده سواء
من الجمهوريين او الديمقراطيين في مجلس
النواب فالجمهوريون ينتقدون ما وصفوه
بتنازلات قدمها مكارتي اثناء مفاوضاته
الماراثونيه مع بايدن اما الجمهوريون
ينتقدون قيود الانفاق على البرامج المحليه
ومع ذلك يامل الجمهوريون في مجلس النواب
بتامين 150 صوتا لصالح الاتفاق فيما ستحسم
اصوات الديمقراطيين الوسطيين المنافسه
للوصول الى
عتبهمانيه عشر صوتا وهي اللازمه لتمرير
القانون من واشنطن ينضم الي مراس له عربيه
سنه توضيح حسين اهلا بك معنا هناك اجتماع
الان للجنه وهي التي تقرر اذا كانت ستمرر
هذا القانون الى مجلس النواب ام لا هل
انتهى هذا الاجتماع وهل من قرارات
تحيه لك يا ميسون المناقشات داخل هذه
الجلسه ما زالت مستمره في لجنه القواعد في
مجلس النواب ولكن بحسب الانباء التي ترجح
الان من هناك بان القانون سيمر عبر هذه
اللجنه ليتم التصويت عليه غدا في مجلس
النواب قبل ارساله الى مجلس الشيوخ طبعا
اذا مر اليوم هذه هي الخطوه الاولى وهذه
هي العقبه الاولى التي تواجه هذا المشروع
قبل ان يواجه ايضا عقب ربما عقبه ثانيه
غدا خلال التصويت عليه في مجلس النواب حيث
سيكون هناك اعتراضات اكبر من قبل
الجمهوريين لاسيما من اليمين الجمهوري غير
الراضي عن ما يصفونه بالتنازلات التي
قدمها مكارتي لبايدن ولكن كما تفضلت
بالخبر سيتم الاعتماد على اصوات الوسطيين
من الديمقراطيين لانه حتى على اليسار
الديمقراطي هناك من يعترض على الاتفاق
ويقول بانه اضر ببرامج برامج الحكوميه
الاجتماعيه بت
الشروط للحصول على المساعدات الحكوميه
خاصه كما قلنا من الديمقراطيين
التقدميين بعد ذلك هذا مر بمجلس النواب
غدا سيكون هناك ايضا مسار صعب في مجلس
الشيوخ حيث اعلن العديد من الجمهوريين من
اعضاء المجلس بانهم يعترضون على هذا
الاتفاق
الجمهوري رانبول الذي قال انه سيصوت ضده
بل وايضا قدم بديلا عن ذلك بان يتم رفع
سقف الدين ب500 مليار دولار ثم يتم
التفاوض بعد ذلك بعد اشهر على اتفاق جديد
لاصلاح الانفاق في واشنطن سين هذه الاجواء
التفاؤليه كيف كان انعكاسها اليوم على
الشارع الامريكي وخاصه الاسواق
بطبيعه الحال عندما يعلن عن توصل الى
الاتفاق هذا ينعكس ايجابيا في الاسواق
الامريكيه الماليه وينعكس ايضا ايجابيا في
الشارع الامريكي لا احد يريد في الولايات
المتحده ان تتخلف الولايات المتحده عن
سداد ديونها وان يؤدي ذلك الى ازمه
اقتصاديه داخليه وحتى عالميه هناك تخوف
حتى دولي من حدوث هكذا ازمه لذلك الاسواق
الان تترقب ما يجري اليوم وستتراقب ما
يجري غدا في انتظار
عطله نهايه الاسبوع او نهار الجمعه لصوت
مجلس الشيوخ على ذلك بطبيعه الحال كما
قلنا كلما كان هناك تقدم في هذا القانون
سيكون لذلك انعكاس ايجابي على الاسواق
وايضا على نفسيه المواطنين الامريكيين
الذين ينتظرون رواتبهم وينتظرون المساعدات
لكي يحصل عليها رواتب التقاعد شكرا لك من
واشنطن مراسل العربيه حسين
الى هنا تنتهي اخبار الساعه لم يبقى سوى
التذكير بابرز العناوين
روسيا واوكرانيا تتبادلان قصف العواصم
وتزايد استهداف الاراضي الروسيه الحدوديه
الاتحاد الاوروبي تعليقا على التصعيد بين
الكوسوفو وصربيا اوروبا لن تستطيع تحمل
صراع جديد
اشتباكات تخترق الهدنه الهشه في الخرطوم
والبرهان يظهر بل يظهر من جديد وينفع اي
دور للاخوان في الحرب
انباء عن توافق جديد على موعد الانتخابات
في ليبيا والمبعوث الامامي ينصح بالمصالحه
اولا
اشكر لكم طيب المتابعه في امان الله
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات